hoy 12 de octubre surgen las opiniones a
favor y en contra de la celebración en
torno a este día que es llamado en
diferente manera en distintos países el
día de la hispanidad el día de los
pueblos indígenas de la resistencia
indígena el respeto a la diversidad
cultural y también del descubrimiento de
los dos mundos según varios
historiadores detrás todo esto existe
una comunidad iberoamericana con fuertes
lazos sociales y culturales esta fecha
viene acompañada además de celebraciones
pero casi siempre politizadas desde la
exigencia del presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador de que tanto españa
como la iglesia católica pidan perdón
por los europeos cometidos hace más de
500 años o las disculpas del papá
francisco por ello te quiero dar la
bienvenida a nuestro segundo invitado al
día está con nosotros en el plató de
directo américa armando uribe valbuena
él es maestro de sabiduría por la unesco
y actual secretario de la instancia
especial de alto nivel de los pueblos
étnicos se es siempre para la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz
también ex dirigente de la organización
nacional indígena de colombia gracias
don armando por estar aquí con nosotros
en directo américa en francés 24 me
pregunto cuál es la lectura que ustedes
le hacen este día el 12 de octubre
en primer lugar un saludo de armonía y
de equilibrio para sonreír en esta
crisis climática para nosotros es la
continuidad de la vida en la resistencia
ante la imposición del pensamiento y la
filosofía
patriarcal en la acumulación del dinero
con los recursos que son nuestros
hemos vivido
tres siglos con el imperio católico que
nos impuso sus normas leyes sus
costumbres y vivimos en una república en
el caso de colombia muy déspota muy
fascista y es casi la historia de todos
los países en américa latina'
seguimos resistiendo
seguimos avanzando en posicionar nuestro
pensamiento son cinco siglos de
resistencia en donde la
pedagogía de la oralidad en nuestros
idiomas se mantiene se recupera se
reposiciona y simplemente le estamos
diciendo a la humanidad aquí estamos
para vivir en armonía en equilibrio en
solidaridad y reciprocidad para que las
leyes de la naturaleza se mantengan y
puedan controlar y mantener la vida de
las nuevas especies entre ellos los
seres humanos con este cambio climático
además como bien lo comentaba también le
quiero preguntar y quiero pues sacar a
colación el tema que usted tocó es un
poco hipócrita no la política de
nuestros líderes latinoamericanos
exigiendo respeto a pues el imperio
español pues a los españoles en este
caso cuando en qué condiciones viven las
comunidades indígenas en nuestros países
en en américa latina hay muchos pueblos
nómadas ningún gobierno de américa
latina ha reconocido los derechos de los
nómadas tampoco el de los semi nómadas y
el de los sedentarios ha sido un
reconocimiento
parcial
es una exigencia que debemos de hacer
los pueblos indígenas pero colombia que
ha sido una de las primeras
constituciones aún no se respeta al ser
humano indígena está el caso al norte de
colombia donde mueren miles son varios
miles de niños que mueren por causas del
extractivismo minero y el cambio
climático ya que no hay alimentos que
puedan garantizar la repubblica y eso
sucede en todos estos países primero
deben cumplir los mandatos de los
derechos al ser humano y principalmente
a los niños antes de estar pidiendo el
perdón es mejor aplicar los derechos
económicos sociales culturales
ambientales y además los derechos
civiles y políticos que nos corresponden
a los legítimos propietarios de estos
territorios si se cumple todo eso que
está diciendo ahí estaría la fortaleza
de nuestra región de américa latina
allí está allí está porque es el medio
ambiente
es todo el ecosistema el que preservamos
allí está la economía de los nómadas de
los semi nómadas de los sedentarios
también son las garantías de vida de los
campesinos afro raizales que viven en
todo lo largo y ancho de este continente
muy pequeño pero muy valioso que aporta
mucho al ser humano de todos los
continentes porque es la vida es el
oxígeno quién es eso estamos armando
esta realidad
usted ve que puede cambiar en un futuro
en un futuro cercano que están haciendo
ustedes para cambiar que acercamientos
han tenido en específicamente con el
gobierno colombiano el presidente iván
duque para que sean respetados este es
un gobierno que no respeta al ser humano
colombiano
tiene otros comportamientos fascistas
no reconoce la existencia y la propia
república hace pocos días en un
municipio tibú departamento de santander
fueron fusilados dos niños uno de ellos
es un niño wayúu donde es una muestra
clara de que no hay ministerio de
justicia no hay fiscalía general de la
nación y aún hoy no se han esclarecido
los hechos este es un ejemplo de las
cosas que suceden en todos los pueblos
indígenas como en el pacífico donde los
embera no pueden alimentarse no recibe
los nutrientes no reciben las calorías
porque están confinados no pueden pescar
no pueden realizar cacerías ni
recolección de alimentos esto también lo
vemos en los llanos orientales y también
en la amazonía y en todos los pueblos
con este legado histórico retomando ya
también este día el 12 de octubre
ustedes rescatan algo de hace 500 años
simplemente llegaron bajo los
elementos de guerra no conocíamos la
pólvora ni el acero en las espadas
nos fuimos asimilando y nos resistimos
nos resistimos con el intelecto la
filosofía el pensamiento para recuperar
que las leyes de la naturaleza sigan
existiendo hay algo muy sencillo y
simple el sol calienta las aguas del mar
y de allí nacen las lluvias y también el
viento esa es nuestra historia de origen
occidente se llama fotosíntesis pero la
economía quiere aplastar todo lo que
produce la fotosíntesis la polinización
de los animales y los vegetales y eso es
acabar la economía y el sistema
alimentario de los pueblos indígenas y
de todos los americanos también estamos
hablando previamente con usted con jose
manuel azcona catedrático de historia
contemporánea universidad rey juan
carlos de madrid él decía que pues
ustedes tampoco habían sido un pueblo
pacífico que le respondería
somos culturas distintas
ellos son patriarcales nosotros no somos
ni patriarcales ni matriarcales tenemos
la modernidad de unas estructuras de
familia acorde al ecosistema y a las
leyes de la naturaleza ya para finalizar
armando siempre latino a vivir
entonces con el estigma de la
colonización
poco a poco vamos levantando las la
península ibérica' de 800 años de
resistencia contra el mundo árabe
nosotros llevamos 500 300 con el imperio
católico 200 con esta república y ahí
mantenemos los ánimos para la vida y la
dignidad y recuperar reposicionar la
libertad de los pueblos originarios de
este contiene